>> GUYS IT'S TIME FOR
TONIGHT'S #WARS.
>> WAR!
>> LAST WEEK OUR FIRST WEEK
ON THE SHOW THE HASHTAG WARS
KIND OF BLEW UP.
THIS WAS TRENDING WORLDWIDE,
SO YOU GOT OH, APPLE, THEN
SOMETHING IN RUSSIAN, AND
THEN OH THIS IS ONE OF THOSE
DAYS, AND THEN SLUTTY
MUSICALS, WORLDWIDE.
FOR NO REASON.
ALL RIGHT, GUYS, I'M GOING
TO GIVE YOU A HASHTAG AND
BUZZ IN WITH THE TWEET THAT
REFLECTS THE HASHTAG.
YOU WILL GET $100 POINTS.
TONIGHT'S IS SPOOKY CELEBS.
EXAMPLES MIGHT BE LEONARDO
DECAPITATED OR BRAD PITT OF
ULTIMATE DESPAIR OR TERROR
REED.
I WILL PUT 60 SECONDS ON THE
CLOCK.
>> OH YEAH.
>> WHY NOT 120 SECONDS.
>> YOU JUST GET 60 SECONDS
YOU-- ADORABLE IMP.
>> SCARY FISHER.
>> YES, POINTS.
>> KRISTEN SCHAAL.
>> MOAN-IQUE.
>> YES.
>> DOUG BENSON KEISHA FRIGHT
POOLIAN.
>> YES, CHRISTIAN SCHAAL.
>> CATHRY BAIT AVND SWITCH
ME ALL THE WAY TO HELL.
>> MARILYN MANSON WOULD BE
JELL US HE DIDN'T COME UP
WITH THAT, POINTS.
YES, KRISTEN.
>> TINA FANG.
>> MY BUZZ CERTIFICATE NOT
WORKING.
>> CHRISTIAN SCHAAL.
>> YES, DOUG BENSON.
>> DOUG BENSON.
>> HONEY BOO BOO.
>> MYA RYU DOLPH THE RED
NOSE REINDEER GOT DUG UP
FROM PET CEMETERY.
>> YES, POINTS, LET'S GIVE
EUGENE.
>> MYA ANGEBOO.
>> BENEDICT CONVER --
>> I KNOW.
>> I WILL GIVE YOU GIVE YOU
ONE FROM BENEDICT
CUMBERSNATCH.
THAT IS VERY SPOOKY.